confinement total le week-end bas s'ils
prennent de telles mesures je pense que
c'est par rapport à tout ce qui se passe
donc c'est peut-être nécessaire après
c'est un peu compliqué d'appliquer sa
sur paris vous avez juste à vous
retourner à regarder un c'est le seul
moment où les parisiens ils profitent
c'est le week-end donc c'est très
compliqué je pense de faire ça sur paris
là on va concerner les gens en fait les
week-ends et avec l'arrivée du printemps
on va faire comment pour les autres
jours c'est ça en fait aussi un c'est
archi morts nous rencontrons pas à ces
morts mais j'en ai même pas confiné
confinement à 18 heures je te gâche pas
on sort du studio il est déjà 22 heures
23 heures c'est mort ces morts ces morts
toi tu vois tu confies nettoie à 18h la
personne qu'elle confiait il ya des
réchauds jusqu'à 20 heures
ouais c'est pas possible et en plus le
week-end quand il commence à faire beau
dans sa lettre la crise si nancy
fonctionnement le week end c'est pas
possible
ben moi je pense que ce serait quand
même compliqué parce que le fin sachant
qu'on est étudiante
le week-end c'est le seul moment où on
peut un peu sortir et c'est donc je
pense ce serait dur bah je pense
honnêtement je pense que j'aurais pas
trop le jeu l'autre est à moitié dans un
souk torturé mais pas avec 20000
personnes je pense que il y aurait juste
mon groupe d'amis proches et ils vont
sortir et ensemble le week end
bon écoute et oui pourquoi pas mais moi
je trouve que c'est une mesure qui n'est
pas qu'il est inutile en fait parce que
regarder beaucoup de gens qui sortent
dans la semaine et c'est pas le fait de
reconfirmer le week-end qui va changer
les choses
lens je confirme pas cette confirmant du
tout et je veux rendre plus qu'il enlève
le couvre-feu car on a commencé vraiment
être psychologiquement pas bien du tout
et
c'est dur de vivre comme ça en plus pour
quelqu'un comme étudiant comment je vais
pas en france je suis là ça fait trois
ans pour mes études et je suis passé de
famille à ses potes à c'est comme ça que
je peux aller rester chez eux des faits
comme ça alors je vous retrouve tout
seul me plains pas et c'est pas bien du
tout non je ne comprends pas ça ben moi
j'avoue que j'aurais pas le jeu moi je
pense que c'est pas trop une bonne idée
mais bon après forcément ce pour un
petit peu sortir etc
mais bon on peut au film au final
consignes et les plus d'un certain âge
c'est surtout qu'ils sont qui sont
vidées après c'est vrai que nous aussi
mais bon un petit peu moins quand même
et puis bon en général quand on sort on
a tendance à rester avec les même genre
de groupes d'âge de personnes donc on
s'est un petit peu moins risqués ont
fait quand même attention aura donc vous
faites nous confiance pendant la semaine
ça me dérange pas trop il serait plutôt
pour
tant que je peux sortir avec mon chien
oui ces trucs oui mais franchement je
tiens à elle pas de jouer donc c'est
normal nous les vieux on attend on
attend la piqûre on ne nous aide pas la
mairie va on a les a appelés à veiller
pas de pitié pas de figure qu'elle
voulait que je lui dis si tout le monde
fait attention monsieur ça fait un nom
fournir que je me confie j'ai 79 ans
j'ai eu deux pensées et je n'ai rien
c'est que je fais très attention
j'ai ma petite bouteille dit drogba
chaque fois que je vais dans le métro de
là mais je sois jamais c'est tout j'ai
jeu jusqu'à maintenant depuis un an bon
faut dire que bon g
je 74 ans donc il est bien évident je
prendre moins de risques
les jeunes bah oui ça serait dur mais je
les fais bon et en rend à la limite
c'est moins peut-être moins difficile
pour moi que pour les jeunes en plus je
mange de la place chez moi je voilà quoi
oui je souhaite que ça n'arrive pas